hey this is presh tallwalker
o is a quarter circle with radii o a and
ob
pick c along ob and pick d along the arc
a b
such that c d a is a 90 degree right
angle
if c d is equal to 7 and d a is equal to
24
what is the length of oc equal to
i thank moas for the suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
i will present two solutions to this
problem
the first solution involves a reflected
quarter circle
reflect the quarter circle o about ob
label the image of a as a prime
notice that angle d
is a 90 degree inscribed angle in circle
o
therefore the two chords from d will
subtend a 180 degree arc
in other words if we extend dc to be a
chord of the circle o
it will meet all the way at the diameter
so c will connect all the way to a prime
now construct ac
adc is a right triangle with legs of 7
and 24
so we can solve for its hypotenuse using
the square root of 7 squared plus 24
squared or we could just remember the
triple 724 25.
now what is the length of a prime c
it's a reflected image of ac so it will
be congruent to ac
therefore a prime c will also be equal
to 25.
now let the radius of the circle be
equal to r
then consider the right triangle ada
prime
one leg is equal to 24 and the other leg
is equal to 7 plus 25 which is equal to
32 and the hypotenuse is equal to 2r
therefore we have 24 squared plus 32
squared is equal to the quantity 2r
squared
we can simplify this equation and solve
for the positive value of r to get that
r is equal to 20. so the radius of
circle o is equal to 20.
we'll substitute that in
finally let's focus on the triangle aoc
we can solve for oc because it will be
equal to the square root of 25 squared
minus 20 squared
this is equal to 15.
we could also notice this is a scaled up
345 right triangle
but the answer is that oc is equal to 15
and that's one way to solve the problem
now on to solution two that involves a
cyclic quadrilateral
let's start from this part of the
diagram notice that angle d plus angle o
each of them is equal to 90 degrees and
their sum will be equal to 180 degrees
in the quadrilateral aocd
two of these opposite angles have a sum
equal to 180 degrees
therefore aocd is a cyclic quadrilateral
this means we can use ptolemy's theorem
the product of the diagonals of the
quadrilateral will be equal to the sum
of the product of opposite sides
let's construct od which is a radius of
circle o
it will also have a length equal to r
now let oc be equal to x and let's
substitute into ptolemy's theorem
we have 25 multiplied by r is equal to r
multiplied by 7 plus x multiplied by 24.
this simplifies to be the following
equation
25r
is equal to 7r plus 24x
we can solve this equation for r
18r is equal to 24x which means r is
equal to 4x over 3.
let's substitute that value in
from here we will again focus on
triangle aoc which is a right triangle
we have x squared plus the quantity 4x
over 3 squared is equal to 25 squared
we can simplify this equation and
carefully solve for x
we need x to be a non-negative value so
we'll take the positive square root and
get that x is equal to 15 so that's one
more way to solve the problem
what an interesting question
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
[Music]
[Music]
you